foreign
what
I'm trying to make friends with the
aliens
is it just my Tick Tock algorithm or are
we like six to 24 months out from some
kind of apocalyptic event I mean 2020
was depressing AF but at least back then
we were just doing dances on Tick Tock
now my feed is filled with all these six
parters about solar flares and climate
change to Deuce natural disasters and
cyber warfare economic depression human
rights reversals new viral pandemics and
alien invasions like
oh my God I almost died
it's all right it's all right at this
point I'm kind of rooting for the aliens
because it all just feels so damn Bleak
and even though I think some of these
are legitimate timely concerns I've
never been a doomsday prepper like my
anxiety is bad enough on a good day I
feel like I would kind of just prefer to
not think about all the terrible ways
that Society could collapse in the next
five to ten years but I'm starting to
think that maybe those guys are kind of
onto something no but seriously folks
nothing wrong with having some cheap and
cheerful Pantry meals on standby for
whatever minor or major world event we
encounter next so while I'm not exactly
at the point of Readiness to learn how
to hunt squirrels or raccoons I'll show
you how a dietitian will build out
balanced meals in a hypothetical
post-apocalyptic World hey everyone I'm
Abby sharp welcome to Abby's future
bunker
[Music]
thank you
I don't know if I'm laughing because I'm
joking or because I'm taking this so
seriously that it scares the out of
me but hey if nothing else the meals
that I would make in like a hypothetical
post-apocalyptic scenario are really
meals that could save me some serious
coin in the current climate where I just
paid nine dollars for a bunch of half
rotten asparagus that's where we're at
folks now quick disclaimer here folks
I'm trying to keep this light and fun
let's not get into politics or
conspiracy theories in the comments I am
definitely not trying to downplay the
seriousness of a lot of these worldly
issues but I'm also trying to not
perpetuate fear-mongering or conspiracy
I have my own personal fears and
concerns for our world but I'm not going
to be getting into those today so please
do the same in the comments so you know
use this as your entertainment or as
legitimate educational awareness to
complement whatever prepper tips you
find from legitimate Preppers online I'm
just personally interested in taking up
the challenge myself so let's go
shopping but let me pop in here quick
folks I'm super excited to be working
with element again this is a product
that I was using like two years ago when
I was on my breastfeeding Saga and it
really really helped me recover and I
got back into it recently because I've
been out in the sun I've been traveling
a lot this summer and I'm really really
prone to sunstroke and I found this
makes a huge difference in how I feel a
lot of my colleagues who work in Sports
Nutrition also swear by elements
specifically because it's got a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium
and it's got no colors sugars or fillers
I've also found that having my
electrolytes in the morning has had a
really positive impact on my sleep so
even on days where I'm not sweating a
lot I'm usually still going to have at
least half a packet I love all things
spicy so the mango chili is my current
Obsession but I've got nine different
flavors including their new grapefruit
which I love and it's now available year
round right now element is offering my
viewers a free sample pack with any
order so that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight of their
flavors or share element with a salty
friend get yours at drinkelement.com
Abby sharp and remember this is only
available through my link so you've got
to go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-n-t.com slash ABI shark
so in preparation for this video I
watched a bunch of like Doomsday prepper
videos on Tick Tock and they were saying
that there's a big difference between
Panic buying like we did with toilet
paper during the pandemic and curating a
carefully planned Pantry for a scenario
where a we don't have access to
perishables from the grocery store on
the regular and B we don't have
electricity so we don't have any way to
keep perishables cold and we also don't
really have any way to cook them on a
stovetop or in a microwave so basically
we gotta think about building meals and
finding ingredients that could be cooked
very quickly on gas or on an open fire
if you're really hardcore and that don't
require any Refrigeration so let's start
with our protein list I would be
stocking up on protein powder canned
tuna canned chicken lentils canned beans
peanut butter nuts bone broth hemp
hearts powdered milk nutritional yeast
and shelf stable Dairy next let's talk
about produce it may not be pretty but I
would be going for a canned vegetables
canned fruits freeze-dried fruits and
dried fruits or dates we also have to
think about whole grains I'd be looking
for a quick cooking grains like white
rice quick cooking oats couscous or
short cut pasta whole grain crackers
nutrient dense high fiber cereal and
obviously boxed mac and cheese sure it's
not whole grain but it's damn Delicious
and for fats obviously we'd be looking
for shelf staple oils like Olive or
coconut oil okay
post-apocalyptic bunker Pantry stocked
let's make some meals okay so seeing as
95 of our meal Inc ingredients are
canned goods I'm trying to find my can
opener and for the life of me oh she's I
got it
oh this is the only thing that matters
if you didn't have a can opener in the
apocalypse you're dead Okay you're just
dead so make sure you have a backup is
what I'm saying
oh
I was just texting all of my apocalyptic
neighbors and in a real apocalypse they
probably would be like off also we
probably would not have cell phones so
yeah never mind I found it smiley face
an opener
two
learn how to use it I've had
a lot of employees over the years and
none of them know how to use my can
opener it takes a Special Touch which is
why in The Apocalypse I will survive no
maybe not
yeah okay so before the Wasps descend
we're gonna make some oatmeal now I have
to be honest I've never cooked anything
other than meat and vegetables on my
barbecue we're gonna call this
apocalypse light because I'm not gonna
build a fire from scratch in my downtown
backyard so we're gonna cook this over
gas outside I probably need an oven mitt
I'm pretty sure that would be important
I got some oats here Pantry staple
cheap and cheerful
nice pick the wrong shirt guys I've got
some canned evaporated milk smells good
mmm sweet
this is a bit of a bougie apocalypse but
let me tell you folks I'd be stocking up
on this you want to talk Panic buying
this is the aisle I'm going for forget
the toilet paper you know forget that
the vegetables I'm going straight for
the hemp hearts you guys know that
obviously
put some of that in there
let's do some peanut butter oh she's hot
so many mistakes have been made already
like I'm so ill prepared for this
cooking session I'm sweating I don't
have anywhere to put my utensils down
that's relatively clean and that's out
here
maple syrup
because when you're having a rough day
you know spoonful of sugar makes the
medicine go down that's what they say so
I'm gonna put a little bit of water
we would have carbon filters in the
apocalypse right
I would I'm gonna pop a lid on
go get another mint
maybe turn that up
I'm gonna slide it a few moments later
oh we did it
okay
okay I'm more worried about the WASP
than I am about dying by rabid animal
okay I've got some protein powder here
obviously we would have protein powder I
would at least maybe you would too
the fear
of
this scenario is making me a little
wonky
I'm just I'm moving my feet
I'm scared scared they're gonna get me
oh yeah
it's gonna be good
all right let's serve her up what I'm
hot and I'm bothered I'm not cut out for
this life guys
I'm just not okay so realistically I
feel like you wouldn't want to waste
more water cleaning a dish so we gotta
eat out of here I've got some
freeze-dried berries
I mean
these would be perfect for a
post-apocalyptic scenario because they
crunchy they sweet they last literally
forever I don't even know but I think
we'll be okay and now we have to
carefully eat this oh
my God okay I think it's one of these
situations
all right
it's good
pop you want to try
a bit hot
so give it a little give it a
blow
sharing is caring
you got to keep those fur babes alive
too success I had to change my outfit
because I was sweating buckets
and y'all know we don't have enough
water to go around so this was necessary
all right folks let's make lunch and of
course we're gonna do some mac and
cheese we're just waiting for the
post-apocalyptic construction to die
down here the aliens are building their
home next obviously mac and cheese okay
because if I'm going down I'm taking my
mac and cheese with me okay we love a
good convenience meal around here so
let's cook some pasta
I guess we got no more clean water
I gotta let that come to a boil I'm
losing my mind here okay so that
literally took a million hours and I
almost was stung about 20 million times
during the episode well we got pasta now
we flavor it up so a little while ago
there was a ton of talk about how boxed
mac and cheese was filled with falfait
phaltates phthalates I can never say it
right phthalates which as I talked about
in my video are those endocrine
disrupting chemicals that we want to cut
back on so I'm pretty sure if it was the
end of the world I wouldn't give a
but because I am going to probably serve
this to my kids later my little hack is
to use just a little bit of the cheese
powder because this is where the edcs
are and then I flavor it up with other
stuff we're going to throw in our
evaporated milk
struggle such a throttle okay I got some
nutritional yeast and that's going to
stand in for some of that cheesy powder
plus it's going to add lots of B12 and
some protein give that a stir I've also
got some shelf stable grated cheese
product I've never really understood
what this is but uh yeah again in an
apocalypse not sure I would care if it
tastes cheesy I'm here for it tiny tiny
bit of coconut oil in lieu of the butter
note to self in an apocalypse maybe get
some dairy cows because I'd be missing
that all right I've got some white
kidney beans this is going to stand in
for a good amount of protein plus some
extra fiber you gotta stay regular when
you're trapped in a bunker with people
that you've basically exclusively only
been hanging out with for Lord knows how
long and then I've got some canned
vegetables and I always forget about
canned vegetables I mean it smells a
little bit like a nursing home which is
depressing in itself but we still need
to get our badge in folks so this will
do the trick just gonna add some more
cheese on top
just dump the whole thing honestly when
in doubt just add more cheese it makes
everything better we all know that you
don't need the Russian food or anything
no we don't need to ration food at all
here this is one day of Apocalypse folks
just one
okay
um let's serve her up I'm pretty sure we
already used up all of our dishwashing
water on hydrating me after I almost had
heat stroke wearing a sweater in the
middle of summer but here we are and I'm
actually excited about this
[Music]
um
I can get down with this the white beans
are really nice they add a nice like
little bit of a texture and chew
um you're gonna be into this the kids
are getting into this too probably a
little for you and then we save the rest
for the Kinders
she's into it
I need you Poppy
I need you
alright everyone it is dinner time and
we are starting with a staple rice it
literally took me two hours to cook this
and what I've learned is that it
probably would have taken me a lot less
time to learn how to build an actual
open fire to cook over than it did to
make rice on my barbecue regardless here
we are we got some rice which I may or
may not have overcooked no it's perfect
it's perfect I've got some light skip
Jack tuna I usually buy skipjack over
albacore because it's lower in Mercury
though I'm pretty sure in an apocalypse
scenario I wouldn't give it we got some
canned mushrooms honestly I kind of
forgot how many great options there are
in the supermarket in the canned
vegetable and fruit department so we got
lots of ways to get our fiber in folks
we got some can oh geez that's gonna
stink for a while
canned beans it'd be nice if they
oh my gosh guys look at this
there's a rogue mushroom
in my green beans
Walmart
get your together and then
I got these cute little baby corn those
came in a can as well nice now a few key
condiments I feel would be important if
you're living in the apocalypse soy
sauce being one of them so we're gonna
give a little bit of that and I like to
do like a kind of salty sweet
combination so I've got a little maple
syrup and then that's gonna be hot I
just know it we're gonna mix it all up
so to recap we've got our carbs here
very important for energy if we did need
to run away from I don't know like a
zombie an alien another human a bear I
don't know what's going to be out there
folks but we gotta learn how to run is
all I know we got our carbs we have some
protein in our tuna plus some Fiber in
all the veg I threw in there and then
I'm gonna top it off with some healthy
fats some cashews I might be lacking
some color but I feel like we're just
gonna have to get used to that I feel
like this YouTube video could be titled
a myriad of ways either post apocalypse
meals or college meals or cheap and
cheerful meals I think there's lots of
benefits to coming up with things you
can make from your pantry
oil pop you're gonna love this get it
get it get it get it
I mean we might be struggling but I feel
like Poppy's gonna be all right all
right finally we got to dessert and I'm
not sure how your priorities stock up in
a post-apocalyptic world
but I mean I feel like enjoyment and
pleasure in what's left of this life is
high out there for me so I don't know
maybe I would just eat s'mores
maybe that would be all that I wanted to
eat regardless I'm definitely having
dessert so let's roast some marshmallow
on my Barbie eventually oh no
mistakes have already been made I'm
usually like a full bird to a crisp give
me all the carcinogens kind of
marshmallow gal but on the barbecue
that's going to take me all effing day
and we need to save our energy for I
don't know like whatever else you get up
to when the world is ending
it's gonna have to be good enough
the makeup is just
running off my face
note to self
don't wear makeup in Apocalypse oh she's
coming she's gone
that's what she said
why don't we just do this all year round
I gotta really re-evaluate my priorities
in life because I feel like s'mores
should be an everyday we're still here
living Our Lives kind of thing
obviously it doesn't have all the
nutrition that you need but sometimes
you just need a little bit of pleasure
to get you to that next day and s'mores
I don't know it would do it for me
well folks I'm not sure if I feel
inspired ill-prepared anxious or just I
guess happy that I was able to make a
full day of meals on the cheap a
reminder here that I'm not trying to
downplay the seriousness of these
worldly issues and I'm also trying not
to perpetuate fear-mongering or
conspiracy so just a friendly reminder
to take this video for whatever works
for you so I guess if we can use this
for nothing else and I hope that we use
this for nothing else let this be a
grocery guide for the days when things
get financially tough minus the hemp
hurts because yeah that might not be
realistic but on that note I think I'm
gonna go Google how to build a fire so I
hope that you guys enjoyed this video it
was fun for me to think about even
though at the same time it's kind of
scary to have to think about but if you
guys like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up if you'd like some more
Pantry meals for whatever reason
apocalypse aliens a solution to the
price gouging that is happening in
grocery stores today let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to hit
up my description for my 300 crushing
comic book ebook and I'll see you next
time on Abby's bunker beam me up
foreign
[Music]